as a human rights lawyer and critic of
Bashar al-assad and while boonie has
been trying to bring Syrian perpetrators
of torture to justice
now he's grappling was property rights
law we meet him in Berlin his new home
since he fled Syria four years ago I
boonies phone has been ringing nonstop
since Assad issued his so-called decree
number 10 refugees all over Europe have
been seeking his advice many of them
still owned property in Syria they're
really worried most Syrians would like
to return home someday when it's safe
and people feel they can live in freedom
but they don't know how they can declare
ownership of their property and now
they're afraid they'll lose their houses
and their lands from this decree they're
afraid of losing their right to return
home the new decree is part of the
government's strategy to rebuild
war-torn Syria when a local development
plan is announced citizens are required
to prove their property ownership within
30 days but most refugees from Syria
like such documents they are afraid of
being arrested if they return if they do
nothing the Syrian state will take over
their homes the German government here
in Berlin says the decree is
expropriation under dubious pretext and
we must assume that wizzard conditions
in Syria will be changed to benefit the
regime and its supporters i boonie owns
an apartment in the west of damascus
because he was threatened with arrest he
left everything behind this photo is his
only souvenir of the place my children
the 25 unlike most Syrian refugees I
boonie does have the right paperwork a
traveling to Syria is far too dangerous
now he could lose his flat because he's
certain no one will oppose the decree
these horrendous crimes have been going
on in Syria for years and no one in the
whole world was really interested why
should the international community
intervene now when it only concerns our
houses it makes me sad I'm angry I'm
very disappointed time for a break but
before long his phone rings again anwar
al bunny predicts the first development
plants will be announced at the end of
the month and that his neighborhood who
will likely be included but he insists
that even if he loses everything
he'll never give up hope of her
returning to Syria one day